foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-1401
object class
Euclid
special containment procedures
scp-1401 has been permanently closed to
civilian traffic as of 19th construction
of an alternate Highway linking affected
communities is pending
permanent Road barriers have been
erected to deter automobile traffic
plainclothed security Personnel are to
surveil scp-1401's Termini to deter foot
bicycle or motorcycle traffic from
entering all Foundation traffic along
scp-1401 for purposes of installing
monitoring equipment road maintenance
Etc is to begin and end during daylight
hours only in the event that any stay
within scp-1401 extends past the end of
Civil Twilight Personnel are to park
their vehicles and remain in position
until dawn no Personnel or to travel
along scp-1401 during nighttime hours
except d-class undergoing testing
the foundation is to monitor police
Communications in all regions where
scp-14011 is capable of manifesting for
any report of vehicle activity
indicative of scp-14011 Foundation First
Response assets are to Shadow any known
scp-14011 instances and document their
movements and identities until such a
time as
scp-14011d manifests or mobile task
force Kappa 101 Convoy and special
medical unit 738 arrive on scene
no attempt to intercept or damage
scp-14011 is to be made without mobile
task force Kappa 101 and smu-738 support
in the event of an scp-1401-1 related
incident or an uncontained police
interception Class A amnestics are to be
issued to all survivors and First
Responders
referred to addenda for information
regarding disposition of scp-14011
passengers
description
scp-1401 is a former stretch of U.S
highways initially paved during the
first wave of transcontinental motor
Trail Construction in the early 20th
century
scp-1401 stretches for approximately 112
kilometers through Rural and uninhabited
areas of the state linking the cities
and and intersects no other roads or
highways between those two Termini
scp-1401 exhibits no anomalous
properties during daylight hours and may
be traversed safely during nighttime
hours however approximately percent of
Motor Vehicles traveling along scp-1401
regardless of whether they were
traveling East or West do not arrive at
their destination and cannot thereafter
be located by any means
thorough surveys of scp-1401 have
located no trace of any wreckage or
signs of accidents or Collision during
tests conducted with d-class Personnel
driving from one end of scp-1401 to
another on-board monitoring equipment
has spontaneously failed during
disappearances and pursuing airplanes
and helicopters have noted the test
vehicle's headlights spontaneously
deactivating concurrent with equipment
failure as well as instantaneous
disappearance of test Vehicles heat
signature from on-board infrared Imaging
equipment
in tests where aerial Pursuit was close
enough to shine a spotlight directly on
the test vehicle no disappearances have
occurred to date
since scp-1401 was closed to civilian
traffic 57 Foundation test vehicles and
their personnel have disappeared within
as well as three non-test vehicles which
remained within scp-1401 after dark due
to engine failure and subsequently
attempted to return Before Sunrise
scp-1401 does not affect Airborne
Vehicles foot traffic or persons in
non-motorized vehicles based on the
nature of several instances of scp-14011
it can be inferred that scp-1401 has
possessed its anomalous properties since
shortly after it came into service
the foundation became aware of scp-1401
in 19 when traffic along scp-1401
decreased significantly due to the
opening of Interstate which bypassed it
as an arterial Road and a correlation
was first determined between
disappearing motorists in the region and
persons traveling along scp-1401
scp-1401 consists of several hundred
anomalous motor vehicles with license
plates and physical descriptions
matching those of vehicles known to have
disappeared while traveling scp-1401
738 unique instances of
scp-14011 have been identified to date
31 of which have been identified as
former Foundation test Vehicles the
oldest identified instance designated
1401-13 is a 1916 Ford Model T the
newest
scp-1401-1732 is a 2006 Toyota Camry
formerly used as a foundation test
vehicle the total number of scp-14011
instances is unknown based on the rate
of occurrence and historical rates of
traffic along scp-1401 the total number
of vehicles affected by scp-1401 is
speculated to be in excess of 10 000. 87
percent of scp-14011 instances have been
cited within a 1 000 kilometer radius of
either of scp-1401's Termini however
scp-14011 manifestations are capable of
occurring in any jurisdiction that has
paved roads where Motor Vehicles drive
on the right side of the road and
Automobiles manufactured for the U.S
market are legal for on-street driving
all scp-14011 instances have been
observed only during night time hours
upon manifesting shortly after dusk an
instance of scp-14011 will proceed to
drive in no particular direction upon
any highways arterial roads surface
streets alleys or back roads legally
open to civilian traffic without parking
or stopping except for traffic lights
stop signs or as necessary to yield to
traffic or pedestrians possessing the
right-of-way if not interfered with
scp-14011 Will obey all traffic laws
applicable to the jurisdiction in which
it is operating no instance of scp-14011
has ever been observed to refuel or make
any stops of any Nature close
observations of older scp-14011 vehicles
have indicated extreme signs of vehicle
wear and exposure to the elements
including rust damaged tires and
indications of mechanical wear under
which conditions the vehicle should not
be drivable on instances where older
scp-1401 one vehicles have been
approached closely enough to view within
the cabin drivers and passengers have
been observed to be in an advanced state
of age commensurate with the expected
age of persons traveling in the vehicle
at the time of its initial disappearance
scp-14011 will de-manifest shortly
before Dawn the nature of
demanifestation has never been directly
observed in all cases where police or
Foundation Personnel have shadowed an
scp-14011 vehicle it has either eluded
Pursuit shortly before demanifesting or
spontaneously deactivated its headlights
and disappeared from infrared monitoring
similar to The Disappearance of vehicles
within scp-1401
after demanifesting an instance of
scp-14011 May manifest again after Civil
Twilight in any region where it is
capable of Legally operating as
described above intervals between known
manifestations of a given scp-14011
instance have ranged from three days to
17 years
scp-14011 Vehicles will resist any
attempts to pursue intercept or force it
to a stop and are capable of reaching
speeds in excess of 300 kilometers per
hour regardless of the top speed of the
original vehicle until crashing or
pursuers abandon the attempt attempts to
fully stop scp-14011 vehicles with spike
strips caltrops or other anti-vehicle
implements have been unsuccessful
resulting only in a brief loss of Spate
as long as the vehicle remains intact
and in contact with the road it will
continue to flee pursuers at high speed
no instance of scp-14011 has lost
control or determined to have been at
fault in a collision in all documented
instances to date were in scp-1401
vehicle has been stopped cause of
deceleration was due to another vehicle
deliberately or accidentally striking it
or placing itself directly in its path
in all cases where an scp-14011 vehicle
was recovered the gas tank was found to
be empty older vehicles were found to
have suffered several major engine
failures which under normal
circumstances would render automobiles
inoperative and attempts to restart said
Vehicles after recovery have been
unsuccessful
agenda
scp-1401-1 passenger medical analysis
to date 37
scp-14011 vehicles have been
successfully stopped during Pursuits by
Foundation Personnel or civilian First
Responders in 23 instances the stop was
achieved by means of a direct collision
with no survivors on board the scp-14011
vehicle following the development and
implementation of procedure 14011 Delta
which involves reducing scp-14011
velocity with spike strips and by
grinding Pursuit Vehicles against its
side prior to forcing a spin out with a
modified pit maneuver 14 vehicles have
been recovered with minimal
collision-related injuries to passengers
on board in all cases where
identification has been possible the
identities of passengers have been
matched to those of persons known to
have been traveling in scp-14011 at the
time of its disappearance passengers
have been designated based on the
vehicle they were recovered from and
their seat position clockwise from the
driver's seat
in almost all cases where in scp-14011
passengers were recovered alive the
passengers died less than 60 minutes
after scp-14011 was stopped apparent
biological age of passengers is
commensurate with their presumed age
given known dates of birth passengers
display acute signs of dehydration
starvation bed sores deep vein
thrombosis and other symptoms consistent
with Advanced age and with remaining in
a stationary position for long periods
of time without exercising rudimentary
bodily functions death occurs as a
complication of these circumstances in
several cases passengers were found to
be in the advanced stages of fatal
communicable diseases which contributed
to their death to subjects
scp-1401-12373 and
scp-1401-16541 were pregnant at the time
of recovery medical records indicate
that both subjects were pregnant at the
time of their appearance in 1973 and
1922 respectively fetuses showed signs
of advanced age and illness commensurate
to adult passengers and did not survive
in 2000 special medical unit 738 was
established for the purpose of
responding to scp-14011 events and
Performing on-site emergency medical
treatment for scp-14011 passengers in
the hope of recovering passengers alive
to date 12 passengers have survived past
the 60 Minute Mark two
scp-14041-3321 and scp-1401
17023 are conscious and able to speak
both however are confined to bed rest
due to severe muscular atrophy and
require 24-hour nursing care at this
time
interview 1401 332-1
interviewer Dr s samesh interviewee
scp-1401
1-3321 Hereafter referred to as Adam
forward
scp-1401-13321 Adam
disappeared with his wife and two
children in June 1932 while driving West
along scp-1401 in a 1928 Ford Model A
vehicle was first identified by the
foundation in 19 and designated
[Music]
scp-1401-1332
scp-1401-1332 was recovered intact
following a Pursuit on 2000
SMU 738 was unable to save any
passengers except the driver
biological Age based on medical
examinations and birth documents is
presently 100
due to injuries noted at time of
recovery is unable to walk or stand
under his own power and frequently
require supplementary oxygen in order to
breathe
begin log 20 3 12 pm
can you tell me how long you were
driving for before the police stopped
you
and stuff
half past be careful
be careful we were driving at night to
beat the Heat and the dust you see
some didn't ever come
a commitment more than
more than it gets no clock in there and
the radio's busted
felt like years though how far did you
drive during that
picture lost track
the Old Dominion
do you ever need to California
sure kept driving I didn't like the
little girl pledge you must have needed
to refill your gas tank at some point
yes
never needed to good thing too it was 10
cents a gallon back home but some of the
stations out here you wouldn't believe
how much they're charged
did you ever stop to eat or use the
facilities
it wasn't really that hungry
none of the restaurants are seen around
here look very good anyway
did you stop at any time for any reason
why bother
we were making great time
I know we're any good to pull over
anyway
did you notice yourself for your family
aging during the trip yeah I guess we
got a few more wrinkles now than I used
to and the boys
well they say kids grow up in the blink
of an eye but I wasn't expecting it to
happen that fast
why did you attempt to do away Pursuit
when the police turned their lights on
don't make me out like I'm some kind of
book I wasn't trying to kill a suit or
anything like that I just didn't feel
comfortable going over in that
neighborhood
you continue to lead the police on a
chase for 238 miles across three states
before you were forced
with any acceptable places to pull over
at any point during the pursuit
between co1
what would you have considered a good
place to stop
first one
I haven't seen it
Jesus
and log 20 3 18 pm
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to zargaron
they accept
oh crop guy
Trey Adams
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
your local Foundation agent
sagnar
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Dean dingus
braided Peach
Rowan O'Brien
cake knock
gremnir
extra moments one two three
[Music]
and James Wright
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you